.
THE LANGUAGE OF THE 12th
AMENDMENT IS THAT SIMPLE.
>> THANK YOU, JUDGE.
>> MR. JACOB, I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU.
I BELIEVE DURING YOUR DEPOSITION
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE, YOU SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF YOU'D
READ EVERY WORD WRITTEN ABOUT
THE 12th AMENDMENT, THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT AND HISTORIC
PRACTICE.
I KNOW IN RESPONSE TO THE
CHAIRMAN'S EARLIER QUESTION, YOU
GAVE YOUR BOTTOM LINE
CONCLUSION.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
PROCESS YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
WENT THROUGH OF RESEARCHING THIS
ISSUE AND WHAT CONCLUSION YOU
CAME TO AFTER YOUR THOROUGH
RESEARCH?
>> SO YOU, AS A LAWYER, WHO IS
ANALYZING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISION, YOU START WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TEXT.
YOU GO TO STRUCTURE.
YOU GO TO HISTORY.
SO WE STARTED WITH THE TEXT.
WE DID NOT THINK THAT THE TEXT
WAS QUITE AS UNAMBIGUOUS AS THE
JUDGE INDICATED.
IN PART, WE HAD A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS IN 1876 BECAUSE IN THAT
YEAR, MULTIPLE SLATES OF
ELECTORS WERE CERTIFIED BY
MULTIPLE SLATES, AND WHEN IT
CAME TIME TO COUNT THE VOTES,
THE QUESTION OF WHICH ONES HAD
TO BE ANSWERED.
THAT REQUIRED THE APPOINTMENT OF
AN INDEPENDENT COMMISSION.
THAT COMMISSION HAD TO RESOLVE
THAT QUESTION, AND THE PURPOSE
OF THE ELECTORAL COUNT ACT OF
1887 HAD BEEN TO RESOLVE THOSE
AMBIGUITIES.
I AM IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
JUDGE.
IT IS UNAMBIGUOUS THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REJECT ELECTORS.
THERE IS NO SUGGESTION OF ANY
KIND THAT IT DOES.
THERE IS NO MENTION OF REJECTING
OR OBJECTING TO ELECTORALS.
IS NOTION THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT COULD DO THAT IS NOT
IN THE TEXT, BUT THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAD AND THAT JOHN
EASTMAN RAISED IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WAS WE HAD ALL SEEN
THAT IN CONGRESS, IN 2000, IN
2004 AND 2016, THERE HAD BEEN
OBJECTIONS RAISED TO VARIOUS
STATES.
AND THOSE HAVE EVEN BEEN DEBATED
IN 2004.
AND SO HERE YOU HAVE AN
AMENDMENT THAT SAYS NOTHING
ABOUT OBJECTING OR REJECTING,
AND YET, WE DID HAVE SOME RECENT
PRACTICE OF THAT HAPPENING
WITHIN THE TERMS OF THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT.
SO WE STARTED WITH THAT TEXT.
AND I RECALL IN MY DISCUSSION
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT, HE SAID
I CAN'T WAIT TO GO TO HEAVEN AND
MEET THE FRAMERS AND TELL THEM
THE WORK THAT YOU DID IN PUTTING
TOGETHER OUR CONSTITUTION IS A
WORK OF GENIUS.
THANK YOU.
IT WAS DIVINELY INSPIRED.
THERE IS ONE SENTENCE THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
SO THEN WE WENT TO STRUCTURE.
AND AGAIN, THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
FIRST INSTINCT HERE IS SO
DECISIVE ON THIS QUESTION.
THERE IS JUST NO WAY THAT THE
FRAMERS OF THE CONSTITUTION WHO
DIVIDED POWER AND AUTHORITY, WHO
SEPARATED IT OUT, WHO HAS BROKEN
AWAY FROM GEORGE III AND
DECLARED HIM TO BE A TYRANT.
THERE WAS NO WAY THEY WOULD HAVE
PUT IN THE HANDS OF ONE PERSON
THE AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE WHO
WAS GOING TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THEN WE WENT TO HISTORY.
WE EXAMINED EVERY SINGLE
ELECTORAL VOTE COUNT THATTED
THAT HAPPENED IN CONGRESS SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE COUNTRY.
WE EXAMINED ELECTORAL COUNT ACT.
WE EXAMINED PRACTICE UNDER THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT, AND
CRITICALLY.
NO VICE PRESIDENT IN 230 YEARS
OF HISTORY HAD EVER CLAIMED TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF AUTHORITY,
HADN'T CLAIMED AUTHORITY TO
REJECT ELECTORAL VOTES.
HAD NOT CLAIMED AUTHORITY TO
RETURN ELECTORAL VOTES BACK TO
THE STATES.
IN THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES, NOT ONCE HAD A
JOINT SESSION EVER RETURNED
ELECTORAL VOTES BACK TO THE
STATES TO BE COUNTED.
AND IN THE CRISIS OF 1876,
JUSTICE BRADLEY OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT WHO
SUPPLIED THE DECISIVE FINAL VOTE
ON THAT COMMISSION HAD
SPECIFICALLY LOOKED AT THAT
QUESTION, AND SAID FIRST, THE
VICE PRESIDENT CLEARLY DOESN'T
HAVE AUTHORITY TO DECIDE
ANYTHING.
AND BY THE WAY, ALSO DOES NOT
HAVE AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION BY SENDING THINGS
BACK OUT FOR A PUBLIC LOOK AT
THINGS.
SO THE HISTORY WAS DECISIVE, AND
AGAIN, PART OF MY DISCUSSION
WITH MR. EASTMAN WAS IF YOU WERE
RIGHT, DON'T YOU THINK AL GORE
MIGHT HAVE LIKED TO HAVE KNOWN
IN 2000 THAT HE HAD AUTHORITY TO
JUST DECLARE HIMSELF PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES?
DID YOU THINK THAT THE DEMOCRAT
LAWYERS JUST DIDN'T THINK OF
THIS VERY OBVIOUS QUIRK THAT HE
COULD USE TO DO THAT.
AND OF COURSE, HE ACKNOWLEDGED
AL GORE DID NOT AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE HAD THAT AUTHORITY AT THAT
POINT IN TIME.
BUT SO, TEXT STRUCTURED HISTORY.
I THINK WHAT WE HAD WAS SOME
AMBIGUOUS TEXT THAT COMMON SENSE
AND STRUCTURE WOULD TELL YOU THE
ANSWER CANNOT POSSIBLY BE THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS THAT
AUTHORITY.
AS THE COMMITTEE ALREADY PLAYED,
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS,
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
UN-AMERICAN.